stade tellement rapide parce que
certaines façons que je te support de
tout terme françois girard a découvert
le jeu de hasard et d'argent en ligne en
2019 c'était pas mal la publicité
sur l'internet ou quelque chose comme ça
qui m'a orienté vers des sites
de jeux en ligne mais c'est en 2020 et
lors de la première année de la pandémie
qu'il atteint le fond du baril manque de
social manque d'activité avec plus de
temps avec ce truc a vu que c'est
accessible 24 heures sur 24
mais sitôt plus de temps mais c'est plus
facile de jouer il est loin d'être le
seul dans cette situation
le nombre d'adultes de québécois qui
joue de l'argent en ligne a grimpé de 7%
durant la pandémie un québécois sur cinq
s'adonne désormais à ce type de jeu et
le car des joueurs disent avoir dépassé
les limites qu'il s'était fixé au point
où certains développent une dépendance
qui doit être traitée depuis le début de
la pandémie on a vraiment vu un 180° si
je peux dire et maintenant 80 % de la
clientèle s'adonnent à des jeux en ligne
est si problématique
le jeu en ligne est aussi plus risquées
que les jeux au casino ou dans les bars
qui ont été fermés pendant la pandémie
il est accessible en tout temps même aux
mineurs et c'est facile de jouer à
crédit ça le propriétaire que c'est
devenu un pays simple qu'elle soit qui
compte françois girard a perdu près de
50 mille dollars en quelques mois des
fois je de
journée ça a été mille dollars
plus qu'une fois notamment avec la carte
de crédit de sa conjointe sans qu'elle
ne le sache je te saoule bord malgré la
ville parce que
parce que je faisais du mal à ma famille
en plus de créer une dépendance les jeux
auxquels jouets françois sont illégaux
québec pas jackpot solide warm up
pourtant leur publicité qu lula la télé
même que des personnalités connues s'y
associent maintenant il dans une note
ces publicités là sont problématiques
parce qu'elles dirigent les joueurs vers
des sites de jeux qui sont pas
nécessairement régulé par loto-québec
donc sont pas des sites de jeux qui sont
les au québec un problème que connaît la
société d'état impuissante devant le
phénomène loto québec peut pas faire de
plaintes au criminel c'est pour on n'a
pas sonné pour ce mandat là ça serait au
chronomètre fédéral et aux instances de
faire appliquer son code criminel les
compagnies derrière ces jeux sont prêtes
à tout pour garder les joueurs captifs
j'ai même fermé mais content j'ai même
changé des e-mails g20 qui ont été
capables de me retrouver sur facebook et
jorge sosa sur son message texte il
m'envoyait sa part la poste malgré leur
insistance une thérapie de trois
semaines a permis à françois girard de
mettre un terme à sa dépendance ici et
lise allard rase au canada montréal
[Musique]